there's something special about
Chancellor Merkel and her phones other
politicians use their devices at least
partially for fun to make videos or take
snapshots on the Bundestag floor Merkel
uses hers for work and as an instrument
of power especially by texting Merkel
reads and writes them throughout her day
anyone receiving a text signed a.m. is
first of all in the know and second of
all important her CD you party cell
phone is a run-of-the-mill Nokia that
even lay persons can crack with software
available online last week Merkel said
important communications were secure I
love stats for all communication on
matters of state there are landlines
encrypted lines and when you're not at
your desk encrypted cell phones that
means all communication on matters of
State is conducted on encrypted phones
built on an unhoned is good food but IT
experts say the government doesn't spend
enough on securing information transfers
not a problem by the problem with
cybersecurity is that it's relatively
expensive you can do different things
the problems weren't so serious until
now so people tried to get by with
cheaper solutions people didn't want to
invest too much each German cabinet
member has an encrypted phone that's
supposedly untap about the Chancellor
has two of them but they're awkward to
use and therefore unpopular users must
enter in 32 characters just to login and
they can't promise 100% security either
especially if the other end of the line
is not encrypted